JZ is spitting the tea on his first
album in four years on the same day we
learned the name of the twins
what a rod really thinks about dating
JLo and our exclusive with Shania Twain
on life love and lust plus I got some
more new music for you because it is
Friday hello friends TGIF
congratulations on making it through the
week as you reward here on the daily
Jennie we will dance to my new favorite
tracks just in time for the long weekend
but first the identity of beyoncé and
jay-z's twins are revealed welcome to
the world Rumi and sir Carter those are
the names it appears the Carters have
named their boy and girl and recently
filed trademark paperwork obtained by et
so in other words Beyonce and jay-z
wasted no time trying to secure the
rights to the names roomie Carter and
Sir Carter now we looked it up ruby
means beauty and flow in Japanese and
sir well that's the perfect name for the
heir of the throne but I want to know
what you guys think I get disappointed
they aren't named red and yellow let us
know in the comments section below all
right but in more Carter news if the
album everybody is talking about
tweeting about gossiping about jay-z is
444 he dropped his thirteenth studio
album today that's right his 13th and in
case you forgot he left it right there
at the top of his album art for you if
you don't have title or are not a sprint
customer I think you should sign up
because you need to hear this record but
if you don't no worries because I am
here to do a deep dive into the lyrics
and let me tell you home had some things
to get off his chest folks online were
quick to point out that the lyrics and
J's first track killed jay-z seem to not
only address Beyonce's lemonade but also
that infamous elevator drama with
Solange and J wasted no time getting
into that with this lyric check this out
you ed Solange on knowing all along all
you had to say you was wrong oh now you
know Solange had a reason to go ham on
her brother-in-law but he never
addressed it until now but the next line
was even more telling you almost went
Eric Benet
a let the baddest girl in the world get
away anyone else
screaming at that all jay-z is referring
to Halle Berry's ex-husband there who
allegedly cheated on her in the early
2000s and lost her for good
so as jay-z confessing that he was
unfaithful to be well on the title track
444 he seems to be doing a lot of
apologizing and he says his heart breaks
for the day he has to explain his
mistakes to his kid and y'all remember
Becky with the good hair yeah she
trifling and Jay references her in the
song Family Feud quote I'll f up a good
thing if you let me let me alone Becky
not to that I say bye Becky it was nice
knowing yes we'll see ya all right
between Beyonce's lemonade and the tea
on Jays album I'm over here sipping on a
satisfying Arnold Palmer folks there was
one revelation on 444 I don't think any
of us saw coming Jays mom Gloria Carter
is featured on her son's third track
smile where she comes out as lesbian
it's the first time either has publicly
addressed her sexual identity in it
jay-z raps mama had four kids but she's
a lesbian had to pretend so long that
she's a thespian cried tears of joy when
you fell in love too matter to me if
it's a him or her I just want to see you
smile through all the hate that deserves
a speak no evil emoji because that was
beautiful and of course Gloria actually
got praised by fans and glad today for
sharing her truth
love is love people and for that we're
going to continue with the theme right
now with one of our new face celeb
couples Jerrod in an interview with
Jimmy Fallon's 1970s era mustache on The
Tonight Show 14 time all-star three-time
Most Valuable Player and veteran of 22
seasons in Major League Baseball Alex
Rodriguez revealed that since he began
dating Jennifer Lopez most people these
days just think of him in a new role
security guard this is like one of the
most humbling experiences of my life you
know when I was in the Yankees and we
want to watch championship and you know
you wear the pin strips you think you're
pretty cool but then you hang out with
Jennifer and they confuse me with the
security guard I'm
haha I promise you we were the med ball
and the paparazzi were screaming at me
not even in English get the hell out of
the way get out of the way really take a
picture
ouch I bet that doesn't happen to Derek
Jeter what still the rod and Jay rod
can't be too upset I mean he may get
pushed aside on the red carpet but he
gets to go home with v flies fly girl
that ever was
Plus y'all moved up to an 8.5 on the
john and christy scale that's not
striking out fam all right but a star
who has hit several home runs in her
story career Shania Twain the country
superstar is back with her first album
in 15 years Shania has made hits out of
heartbreak from her parents death when
she was 22 temporarily losing her voice
after a battle with Lyme disease to her
bitter divorce with music producer mutt
laying after 16 years of marriage she's
been through it all folks and in her new
album now Jen aya seems about recovering
as et found out when we sat down with
her in Nashville I had years and a
lifetime of layers of sadness
you know darkness and negativity that I
just wasn't dealing with and it was like
a floodgate had opened up when I
divorced and the bottleneck was popped
off and it was just time to say what was
on my heart yeah Shania mitts she was
down and out and hit rock bottom and
says you're allowed to feel sorry for
yourself for a bit acknowledge it and
then pick yourself back up even if you
have to climb if you better preach
Shania see we are laying down some
wisdom on you guys today keeping it
positive speaking of it's finally time
to play some beats on you two what
better way to kick off the long holiday
weekend than with some new jams people
Calvin Harris just dropped his new album
funk wave bounces Volume one it's full
of bangers but my pick for you is skirt
on me with the one and only Nicki Minaj
roll it Nealon daily
oh I love that one I love a good
tropical beat love Nikki fear for it all
but I got a little bit of a different
one for you guys if you're a pentatonix
band then you know superfruit the duo is
made up of Scott Hoying and Mitch grassy
check out their visual for their new
single imaginary party especially I'm
trying to be in that video guys hire me
I'm ready for that all right moving on I
know I tend to shade bella thorne on
here but today I've got praise it's her
feature on Prince Fox's just call and I
dare you not to jam out to this one
[Music]
oh yeah I'm here for that song Bella
thank you for that are you guys just
like you I'm also going to be barbecuing
and sitting poolside for the 4th of July
weekend but we are back on Wednesday
with a new daily Denny
so hit subscribe on e t--'s youtube
channel so you don't miss an episode
and of course head over to ET online.com
we are still decoding jay-z's lyrics so
go check that out and until Wednesday
enjoy your holiday folks just ha